prepping for a product management
interview here's an example of a market
estimation question that I often see
what is the market size for hamburgers
in the US
I suggest you tackle this by breaking it
down into smaller pieces you can take
either a top down or a bottom-up
approach to estimate in this case it
might be number of hamburgers eaten per
person per day multiply it by number of
people in the US that actually eat
hamburgers solving questions like these
boils down to making thoughtful
assumptions about the size of a market
dividing it into user segments based on
behavior and then estimating the
frequency at which the action occurs so
for example the action here is customer
purchases the hamburger this type of
formula can be used to solve any large
scale quantity or even Revenue questions
don't forget to do a sanity check on
your answer make sure it's reasonable
remember think out loud and show your
work